on s'entretient avec le directeur de la
police de laval quelques minutes à peine
où on nous disait mais l'on va lancer
une opération parce que le meurtre de du
mafieux salvatore scopalto sheraton
samedi dernier ben ça sonne le branle
bas de combat chez les corps policiers
il faut développer un genre de coalition
entre les différents corps policiers
brian notre analyste en affaires
policières ex-inspecteur aux inspecteurs
à la retraite du spvm et la cc il faut
agir quand on a ce dessin comme celle
d'un message envoyé à l'ensemble des
milieux criminels
oui vous savez ceux des crimes violents
et lorsque c'est dans des endroits
publics comme dans un hôtel il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont innocents qui
sont près de l'événement et ça dépasse
les normes un petit peu la façon que ça
a été fait ça a été exécuté et dans un
coq comme monsieur copé avait déjà été
visé avec plusieurs contrôles sur sa
taille ainsi que son frère son frère
parce qu'apple ne participe pas cette
fête l'on sait déjà qu'ils sont reconnus
comme étant des leaders dans le milieu
et je vous dirais que sauf en sorte que
sont obligés de réagir crs police de
laval est obligé de réagir se greffe à
la grc pourquoi la grc parce que la grc
avait beaucoup de forces ensemble
la sûreté du québec et surtout en
matière de moteur ne servira pas les
avait demandé à la matière de gangs de
rue et la grc pour la mafia italienne
qui se greffe à la grc indiqué la sûreté
du québec
grimpez qu'annick montréal ne participe
pas facile d'en quête la seule sa vie
comme moi que il ya beaucoup de gens sur
le territoire mafieux et ce qui me ce
qui me chatouille un petit peu dans ce
cas ci c'est que même des funérailles a
été reporté parce qu'il y avait des
éléments danger absolument la commune
tes rêves lors des funérailles je sais
que ça se fait dans le quartier italien
sur la rue dante sauver l'église
l'habituel mais pour revenir à la à la
confrontation
c'est sûr que des gens qui ont été
traumatisés de l'événement où l'avait vu
sur des séquences vidéo des gens qui se
cachent et en dessous des comptoirs
partout dans l'endroit ça courait et
tout le monde s'attendait ce qu'est un
tir fou à l'intérieur de cet hôtel là
encore l'événement et on en parlait
plusieurs personnes qui m'en parlent
également dans ce sens que ce qu'on peut
aller quelque part on est à l'abri de ça
mais je pense que non aujourd'hui
ne pas les bris parce que publiquement
dans des endroits publics comme ça sauf
air atteint mortellement de plusieurs
balles par deux individus
puis devant des caméras parce que tout
est filmé famille ne cotisait pas comme
s'il faut disparaître leurs preuves le
véhicule fuyant août font brûler
quelques quelques rues plus loin ou quoi
que ce soit pas du tout il faut leur
crime odieux
parce que un règlement de comptes dans
un endroit où il ya plusieurs victimes
innocentes des traumatismes de ces gens
là oui c'est pas évident mais la normale
samedi que des inspecteurs où il ya des
agents qui est qu'apple leur source dans
les milieux criminels et qu'il a
disputés le savoir faire remettez de la
nano pour qu'on soit tu es vous entre
vous le mets la place publique à
l'époque question est ce qu'on reconduit
ou si on les dit aussi clairement que ça
oui parce que vous savez lorsque ya
jumelles man 2 phrases comme ça c'est
pour avoir une présence accrue sur le
terrain
et comme le dit monsieur brochet airs
probablement des arrestations de briques
conditions d exécution d'un mandat
d'arrestation des mois d'emprisonnement
pour des contraventions non pays
mais la présence fait en sorte qu'ils
vont se faire l'enquêté vont se faire
harceler votre frère vous désirez
protéger parce que d'une certaine façon
le fait qu'on est présents que laisser
les services à bords y sont présents il
y aura une sécurité accrue
c'est la même chose qu'on avait fait
pour les matins quand les lisent les
deux gangs s'affrontaient l'homme on me
dit on va prendre le dessus pourquoi on
va faire revenir au petit vivier souffre
est à placer de ce qu'on a décidé
services de police de mettre en place
l'unité de fausses jumelant les trois
corps de police la sûreté du québec la
grc sa présence mondiale
c'est parce que l'événement avait
dépassé les normes c'était dans un
endroit 16 ans dans une rue avait fait
le faire une explosion victime était une
astreinte complètement oui et ça c'est
pas tolérer c'est pas toléré il faut
qu'on soit là des services de police
soient là pour assurer la sécurité des
gens surtout dans des endroits publics
compte tenu de ce qui se passe dans
milieu dans le moment c'est depuis
l'assassinât de réseau c est ce qu'on
peut croire qu'ils vont entendre ce
message là au regard des derniers jours
déjà
une autre meurtre crapuleux à brossard
dans le quartier dix30 encore là dans un
endroit public république et la nuit
dernière à terrebonne mais cette version
domicile en croit ce sont des endroits
des actes très violent cdd à coup on
utilise les armes à feu
ayons une cible bien établie et ça c'est
un élément danger pour la sécurité de la
population mais il faudra voir les
résultats toujours espérant que ça va
donner de bons résultats
le cimt y aura une bonne journée